so let me start by saying i really
enjoyed this movie
and uh it pulled back the curtain on
something
that i'm really not familiar with and i
have plenty of questions
but i always like starting off when i
have more than five minutes with a few
other kind of questions i promise
they're harmless uh
for each of you uh what tv series would
you love to guest star on
geez you know i haven't really watched
one lately
so i'm sort of i'm sort of lost i you
know honestly if i could
i'd like to go back in time and guest
star on bonanza
okay i didn't know we could go back in
time that's a whole other thing
well i thought i'd throw a qualifier in
there
um working moms on netflix have you seen
this
catherine reitman's show it's not really
you're not really the demographic
frasier
um no i uh it's it's uh
it's yeah it's just a really funny
comedy about
being a mother and also working uh i
don't know what that but it's hard yeah
what would what i don't know what i'd be
on it
going back in time
oh going back in time well obviously i'd
be on cheers or fraser so i could
oh i'll see you again very good it would
have been fun to have you on
so yeah we'll have to deal with that
later uh i am curious
what movie or movies do you think you've
seen the most
and i don't mean during the pandemic i
mean in general
the searchers clue based on the board
game it was a comedy
oh that's funny how you like memorized
it i know it by heart
uh it's very funny and it gets funnier
every time you watch it
it was funny my last question before
getting to the movie
what when was it that you felt like you
could
be an actor and pay rent uh
earlier in your career i started working
when i was still living at my parents
house
because i was underage so um so i
when i started i was lucky because when
i started out and was auditioning i
didn't have to pay rent and then by the
time i moved out
i was working more so i i was lucky that
way
thanks mom and dad yeah mine was a
complete leap of faith i just uh walked
into work one day at o'neill's
on sixth avenue and i thought
i don't want to be a waiter anymore and
i
said to michael the manager i said i got
to quit
i have to and he said i get it
and i walked out i got a job as an actor
the next day and i've never had another
one
that's amazing yeah lucky
extremely lucky jumping into why i get
to talk to the two of you
uh what was it about the script and
story for this particular project that
said i really want to do this
well for me it's always just uh is it a
role i've played before does it talk
about something i don't know about uh
these are all
considerations i make but it's mo it's
primarily i've never
i've never played that note before i've
never played that guy before i've never
done
that thing before and so there were
several of those
things that hit me with this role and uh
it's always nice to be able to i i don't
like to do movies that are trying to
make a point
but one that seems like the story and
and and some sort of message
come along in a in a sort of
seamless manner then i'm okay with it i
mean i don't i don't like
movies that beat you where they have
some sort of message they're trying to
get across
but i didn't i didn't sense that in this
film i sensed that every
each thing that you might take away from
it was uh
trenchant and important and um and so i
really
i really embraced the film and uh found
out along the way that it was really
really hard
it was it took a toll you know it was uh
very emotional and uh and i found a i
found out longing for this character
uh to to make a human connection that he
just was incapable of making
for me there was a really good cast
attached already kelsey and coleman and
janine
um and then the script was just really
lovely and i felt like
uh it got me thinking about moral
issues that doctors faced that i had
never really thought about before i
think
we tend to think of doctors as having a
skill set and they're super human and if
something happens that's a tragedy it's
out of their hands but these doctors
really are making the decision of who
gets to live and who doesn't
um and i had never really thought of
that before
but i feel like the way the movie
handles it in terms of understanding
them as full people outside of the
hospital and
um makes you makes you
it humanizes everybody in the film the
the patients the doctors the
administrators
in a way that i thought was really
refreshing because you know we see
medical dramas all the time on tv
and um and this one just felt special
yeah and i agree with both things that
you guys said um it doesn't beat you
over the head with a message
it's just sort of pulling like i said at
the beginning it pulls back the curtain
on something that i really wasn't
familiar with um yeah i'm assuming both
of you did some sort of research
prior to getting the role or just making
the movie were there any things that
really surprised
you to learn about this process of what
goes on behind the scenes
it wasn't a surprise to me uh it seemed
like it all made sense i mean
even the idea that somebody might want
to try to buy a heart i mean that makes
perfect sense to me but uh
it's uh it's certainly a it's a
complicated world
and that was not a surprise so i mean
i'm not sure i was
surprised so much as just uh
uh in some ways i was disappointed you
know that
we can't just do better but you know
it's there it is i don't know how you
make it better honestly
yeah i mean i think the movie is really
a love letter to doctors and and as
austin describes it it's um it's showing
a well-intentioned but imperfect system
and i think there's been lots of
conversations in the news and
you know about the health care system
and how much it's dependent on and
influenced by money and so
yeah it wasn't a surprise but i was glad
that that was part of our drama
one of the things that i think that the
film touches on which is kind of you
know
it's it's uh the whole message of is it
worth saving
one person to save many or is uh is it
you know where is that line if you will
um
and i found that to be very interesting
and also very honest
because uh there is that influx of money
that
you know that's how everyone it's a very
complicated and dicey issue
and i had no question there i was trying
to go somewhere and it didn't
it didn't go well but you bring up an
interesting idea in the movie too
because
like what i think is that the arguments
on both sides are very balanced
so so you have in that discussion over
this donation that's going to be made to
the hospital if
a certain person gets the heart the
nurse brings up
we could use 25 million dollars like we
need do we need renovations in this
hospital and we can save a lot more
people
if we have a functioning system here um
so
you know which is a valid argument so uh
yeah i think i think that
it the movie is not what what kel what
kelsey was saying about not
liking movies that hit you over the head
with an idea this this
i think what austin succeeded in doing
with this movie is that
um every argument is
a valid one and so you it really is like
it is a really challenging
subject matter an old friend of mine
once said that the purpose of great art
is to
make people ask questions and i think
arguably this movie leaves you with
several and uh
whether or not we've provided an answer
is not really what's important
it's the fact that you're asking them
before i run a time with the two of you
i have an individual question for each
of you uh julie i'm very curious about
this orphan
first kill and the fact that it's a
prequel to a movie from like 10 years
ago
and uh uh kelsey obviously i am
incredibly curious about this
paramount plus version of frasier um
what can you tease people about the
series and when do you start filming
uh well we don't actually have a date
when we're gonna start filming we're
still
kind of breaking the story a little bit
we're doing a polish now uh
we we think we're gonna get most of the
actors back i
i'm fairly i'm certainly hopeful that we
will
and i'm fairly confident that they'll
come back uh
we have a story to tell you know that
can actually
be told with or without them honestly
but it's i want them back because that's
what i always dreamed of i thought we
should explore all their lives and their
third act and so that's that is my hope
but uh
when will we see a frasier probably in
the first quarter of next year
the working title was esther which i
really like which is the name of the
girl but
yeah it's uh what's remarkable is that
isabelle fuhrman who played the little
girl
in the original orphan now reprises her
role
as this the same girl um
same age even though isabelle's older
now she's 23 i think
but i just went and did adr which was
like the the voice recording for it
and i was floored because the tr they
didn't use cgi the tricks that they did
with the camera
um and different like um perspective
tricks that they had uh plus her costume
and prosthetics and all that she looks
like a child
and her performance is stunning because
she
embodies a child too in the way that she
walks and the way she talks and all that
anyway
um but yeah it's uh i think fans of the
first one
um will enjoy this one as well because
there is a huge twist that i can't give
away but it's
got all that crazy psychologically
terrorizing stuff in the fir
that the first one had and just that
this character that isabelle plays
esther or elena or the multiple names
that she has
it's it's like it reminds me of why
norman bates was so captivating it's
just like
a sociopath um but in this child
uh so it was very fun to work on
for somebody who doesn't watch horror
movies
like honestly uh congratulations on this
movie can't wait for the two things you
guys mentioned
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating today thank you
yes